trying to get comfortable just like
breathing for some reason I thought like
it was just something I would know how
to do so I like doping the deep end
obviously then go well got pulled out by
my mom from that point on I just was not
really in the water growing up I didn't
really have that much access to pools I
grew up in Brooklyn so it was really
only when we went to the beach that we
could swim and even then the beaches
were not good so you don't want to
Sunday I remember the movie 300 came out
solid Leonidas right to the edge and
looked down I was like I'm not Leonidas
almost John twice in that report so I
don't accept that cuz my whole black
side of the family like all of them
don't know how to swim so I was like you
know what it's probably part of genetics
[Laughter]
as you can see I'm black and I know very
well how to swim but I kind of grew up
swimming from before I could even talk
and then after that I went on to
becoming a lifeguard and then I have to
become a lifeguard I became a water
safety instructor I could see where the
stereotype comes from some people aren't
so privileged to have access to swimming
pools and their neighborhoods or maybe
their parents couldn't afford lessons or
didn't have the time to even take them
to lessons you know everything plays a
part
we're here to end that stereotype today
day one was like humbling because I
realized I have like this fear of water
that I didn't even realize that keeps
you that you only have one blowing like
that's my oxygen that first day was very
helpful and just like getting
comfortable being in the water to begin
with day one is over with I was kid in
the game I think I was her favorite she
used me to help the rest to instruct the
rest because I was I was the best one
starting off I didn't know what to
expect I think for the very least it
will give me confidence it's been giving
me confidence to not be so careful day
one down feeling like I just want to
stick around and get right back to work
but we'll see the rest of Mako I know
when you pull up in a party black people
tend to not go into the water one of the
reasons is because of here it would
literally mess up our hairstyle
we paid money for it it's a lot harder
to like it sand out of your hair it's a
lot of work to deal with I understand
the feeling I actually just took out my
braids in order to be able to swim
there's ways to get around it you can
always wear a swim cap special shampoos
and conditioners that will strip all
that chlorine out of your hair make it
so where you can still have fun and
still enjoy the water
day to day to yesterday my confidence
going in was a zero damn probably I like
it too today I'm gonna try to just work
on being more comfortable and just let
me go over here yeah I just want to tap
into that and be a little bit more free
today she's talking about jumping off
the deep BAM not yah we this is day two
girl it was nice knowing y'all we're all
gonna die day two was fun because we
would learned how to glide under the
water the gliding teaches you how to
hold your body on top of the water no
kid can teach you how to move you just
want to practice this feeling one two
three
day two we walked out of here a lot of
confidence we were ready to go day three
we lost all of our confidence from my
life flashed before me
[Music]
just trust yourself
I don't Chris had a tough time but I
feel like working together he was able
to relax and about the end of the day he
got it once you go with the flow
everything just comes out naturally it's
plain and simple like anyone can learn
how to swim I just think it's a matter
of like putting in the time and like get
past that fear having a black swim coach
was very empowering she's like a little
mermaid I honestly think the black
people can swim stereotype it's done
away with like it's the 2018 now okay
black people we can swim just stay
relaxed that's the number one have fun
the water is your friend it's all mind
over matter man anything you do in this
life so if you want to start swimming
man do it